une autre sorte de performance matin
celle des couturiers français qui trouve
le moyen de sortir tous ensemble leurs
collections dans la même semaine c'est
la tradition mais c'est quand même pas
bien pratique
cela dit voici de vaud défilé de jolies
mannequins un pôle d'extravagant si au
bout du compte est bien plein les
mirettes pour des spectateurs triés sur
le volet la mode 86 côté dames vu par
france roche la semaine de la mode a
commencé sur les trottoirs de l'avenue
montaigne hommage sur asphalte pour des
couturiers d'hier madeleine vionnet paul
poiret ou pas qu'un des flacons est
passé aux projecteurs pleins feux sur
l'été 86 qui sera d'abord militaire pour
cardin guerrière casque et me walkyrie
me chauve souris pour balmain uniforme
immaculé de fichiers de vaisseau spatial
pour jeunes filles de troupes se grille
de guy laroche et gris encore père les
souris pour philippe venet j'ai
l'impression qu'elle a des contredanses
en retard turbo rose rose comme
l'imperméable de paco rabanne qui aiment
les bras j'ai chanel aussi le bleu de ce
tailleur s'appelle layette coquette
madame grès mlle paille qui a fait cette
rente pleine d'aveux troublant mais
c'est le bleu marine qui domine chanel
par-dessus camélia en hommage à la
fameuse dame et nina ricci des lunettes
pour voir la vie en bleu bleue à pois
blancs ferro blanc à pois bleus hanae
mori blanc / nuit bleue jean denis
cherer bleu uni forme de rente
républicain perse pout qui propose un
sans culotte avec pantalons et des
lampions au poignet révolutionnaire
encore ce décolleté de philippe venet
et toujours un drapeau rouge pour ferro
un drapeau qui se transforme en papillon
papillon qui nous emmène vers les
parterres les poulets volant les jupes
aux coquins comme le fuchsia de guy
laroche qui hésite entre garden party a
french cancan fleurs et tuteurs pour le
co animant
macif prodigue sur les jardinières de
serge lepage et elles ont peur du soleil
les petites fleurs modèle de jean patou
comme sale évanescente et en mousseline
et de carven balma nous propose une
belle rose dans son vase mairie lanvin
deux roses en balade à la recherche de
leurs signes du zodiaque sur les aciers
de mick micheyl est de plus en plus rose
l'orchidée exotiques de pierre cardin
maintenant place aux sherazade voleuse
d'arc en ciel aux peaux d'âne avec leurs
robes couleur du temps soleil et mer
pour nina ricci crépuscule pour givenchy
nuit et jour pour 30
soupir de l'aurore pour rejoindre
richard eyre océans ou forêts endormi
pour paco rabanne enfin pour hanae mori
des couchers de soleil passionnant